نحن نتحدث إلى الناس أيضًا بسبب الكثير من الغضب،
ليس فقط تجاه إسرائيل، بل أيضًا ضد الولايات المتحدة، وكذلك
وسائل الإعلام الغربية، حيث يشعر الكثير من الأشخاص
أن أصواتهم لا تُسمع،
ولا يتم تغطية قصصهم،
استمعوا إلى ما قالته لنا إحدى النساء.
إذا سمعتني، إذا سمعتني حقًا،
فسوف تترك قناتك تمامًا مثل
سفيرك. لا أعرف من الذي فعل
بعض الإنسانية بعض الإنسانية، أعطت الولايات المتحدة
الموافقة لإسرائيل لقتل كل هؤلاء
الفلسطينيين في هذه المذبحة التي كنا
ننام هنا اليوم نحن  استمعت إلى
القنابل، كنت خائفًا وأنا في عمري الكبير،
تخيل الأطفال، تخيل
الأطفال، هل يمكنك حتى أن
تحصل على هذا
الشيء الخاص بك، قليلًا فقط،
سأخبرني أولاً باسمك،
اسمي راه أنا  حسنًا، أيها
المصري،
أخبرني لماذا أنت هنا اليوم، أنا
هنا اليوم بسبب العديد من
الأشياء، أولها الاحتلال غير العادل
الذي استمر لأكثر من 70 عامًا،
وحقيقة أن غزة أُطلق عليها اسم
سجن في الهواء الطلق حيث لا يستطيع الفلسطينيون الوصول
إلى المياه.  لا يوجد وصول لا إمكانية
للدخول أو الخروج غير قادرين على المناورة
لدينا عائلة هنا عائلة فلسطينية
لديها عائلاتها الفلسطينية
هناك، إنهم غير قادرين حتى على سهولة
المناورة، تذهب إلى العطلات، الأمر سهل
بالنسبة لك، ليس بهذه السهولة  بالنسبة لهم، الحياة
صعبة للغاية وهي تتعارض مع
حقوق الإنسان. لقد وصلت إسرائيل إلى حقوق الإنسان
مرارًا وتكرارًا ويبدو أنها
فوق القانون الدولي. نحن
هنا لقول الحقيقة لأن الغرب
كثيرًا ولن أقوم بتعميمه ولكن
كثيرًا.  القنوات الغربية تساعد
في تجريد العرب من إنسانيتهم، أنت تقول ذلك
وعندما أقول كلمة "هه"، كيف
يجعلك ذلك تشعر بأنك تتراجع على الفور
لأن هذا ما كان
يحدث، والآن عندما يموت أكثر من ألف
طفل فلسطيني، فإنك لا تشعر
بنفس الشعور  لا تشعر بنفس الشعور عندما
أقول لك إن أحد أفرادك قد مات ولكن
هذه
ملكنا وهذا أمر غير عادل ومصر
ستقف مع فلسطين. أعرف
السياسة الإسرائيلية وهم يحاولون تقسيمنا
ويحاولون جعلك تبدو  كأننا
ضعفاء ولكن دعني أخبرك بشيء نحن
لسنا ضعفاء ونحن نقف مع
الفلسطينيين ونقف مع العرب وهم
يحاولون تغيير السرد
لأنك تملك السرد، انظر أن هذه هي
مشكلتنا، أنت تملك السرد، أنت
تملك الولايات المتحدة  الأمم التي تمتلكونها هوليوود،
تمتلكون كل هذه الأبواق، أين
أصواتنا، يجب أن تُسمع أصواتنا
أيضًا، لقد كنا نشاهد قناتكم
وبدلاً من الحداد على موتنا
بدلاً من الحداد على هؤلاء
الأطفال الفلسطينيين، كان علينا أن نتعامل مع
المزيد من التجريد من الإنسانية  من العرب، كان علينا أن
نتعامل مع متخلفين أكثر سخافة
لدرجة أن أحد العرب جاء
وحصل للتو على مقابلة مضحكة لأنه
لم يعد هناك أي منطق، لا يوجد
منطق أكثر في الجدال معك، أنت لا
تستمع، كما لو كان لديك إسرائيل
كتاب حقائق إسرائيل عندها كتاب حقائق ح أي
شيء هست
أه الفلسطينيون حيوانات ويجب
أن يموتوا وهذا ما
حدث فلنسمع أصواتنا عبر
تغطيتهم